3-2 au conte étape au sein de notre
travail nous ces deux rencontres 10
parce qu'essentiellement des porte
parole on représente entre 100 et 120
milles construit donc par semaine en
reçoit des centaines de courriels des
centaines d'appels c'est presque
impossible de répondre à tous les
courriels 90% dossiers d'immigration
sédunois tellement complète que nous
c'est ce qui nous occupe à ce que dans
le fond on est comme le pont entre les
citoyens puis l'administration des
impôts diminuent exactement on a aussi
des dossiers agence du revenu du canada
services d'emploi oui effectivement dans
ma propre compte et j'avais deux
inondations en deux ans donc pour nous
j'avais des milliers de dossiers des
gens qui cherchaient comment ils vont
avoir des remboursements à soutenir une
semaine on a cinq six activités des
soupers spaghetti un club d'âge d'or des
cercles de fermières s'arrêtent jamais
et où des assemblées générales
d'organismes de bienfaisance
il n'y a jamais un événement où il faut
pas être présent dans la comté je me
présente aux stations très deux fois par
mois à 5 heures jeudi matin jusqu'à 9
heures du matin et puis dans des cafés
gratuits aux gens c'est pas juste pour
donner des cafés pour vous allez tu as
tu des questions pour - j'ai poursuivi
mon porte-à-porte gens diront qu'une pop
de fait donc presque trois quarts du
comté dans ce rapport là avec les
citoyens c'est l'or qui vont nous dire
ah ben moi j'ai reçu une lettre de
l'agencé pour quoi faire
les new media oui on peut faire ça vous
pouvez nous aider ben oui c'est deux
fois par semaine weight deux heures à
chaque fois les gens ne réalisent pas à
quel point à ses comités là c'est ça qui
nous alimente en termes de réflexion
c'est parce que souvent on voit la
chambre des communes mais la chambre des
communes ce qui s'y passe est le
résultat de tout ce travail là qu'on a
fait en amont c'est là qu'on rencontre
les témoins les experts mais c'est pas
obligé d'être des professeurs
d'université l'eau ça peut être des
familles
des gens qui ont vécu cette réalité
lorsque j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est le
débat à huis clos qu'on ait été député
entre nous et le vraiment ni vol de
manière tout à fait transparente puis on
a des débats virulents des fois mais en
toute amitié collégialité
puis on essaie le plus possible
d'enlever le côté politique on est là
vraiment pour améliorer les projets de
loi la période des questions
c'est le tacle l'opposition a pour
mettre de l'avant des sujets nous on
pose la question pour pour que les
médias nous écoute pas pourquoi le
gouvernement nous écoute tous les jours
quand même pendant qu'on sièges au
parlement
les ministres doivent endurer de l'audi
biel enduré des attaques virulentes qui
répondait fois pendant une semaine sur
la même question et l'objectif attendu
s'est constitué un jour ou l'autre le
ministre a flanché
il va nous dire la vérité et c'est là
que l'objectif recherché de
l'imputabilité de la responsabilité
ministérielle et de la transparence bono
mentale et tactique
la période des questions et est toujours
un peu de théâtre mais ce parce que
c'est devenu encore plus de théâtre
parce que avec les médias sociaux
facebook sur tout le monde cherche un
clip peut mettre sur facebook et ses
s'est pas seulement les d'opposition le
sait tout le monde sait à chaque
mercredi
ces deux lieux ou à huis clos on peut
vraiment partager à nos points de vue
j'ai l'impression que le canada il
réunit ensemble on discute vraiment
fermement il ya des vrais débats
c'est très important d'avoir cette
chance chaque semaine de parler des
enjeux et de voir comment on peut
trouver des solutions qui marchent pour
tout le monde question a complété la
cause le travail de député c'est un
privilège non de voir qu'est-ce qui est
le plus dur dans le travail de député
c'est vraiment de trouver l'équilibré
entre la vie familiale pour moi entre
score et l'avis du député comme on fait
si di papa ne quitte pas encore quand ce
que tu reviens puis je dis toujours je
reviens vendredi soir puis ils
commencent à pleurer ça donc c'est
vraiment dur dès qu'on est allé pisser à
la pharmacie on peut se faire
interpeller sur la vente d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite ou sur un problème
d'assurance emploi ou c'est ça qu'il
faut toujours être prêt à répondre 7 7 6
disponibilité la continuelle je pense
moi c'est ce que je roulais tai chi chi
le plus exigeant moi la chose que je
trouve plus dévissé véritablement c'est
ne jamais être seul parce que moi je
quelqu'un un peu de sauvage est toujours
été un peu solitaire
bien que j'aime beaucoup spécialisés
mais jamais jamais jamais être seul
qu'est-ce qui est le plus gratifiant les
remercie il y avait une jeune de deux
ans qui était pompier
obama ne savait pas de passeport tout
été complètement détruit qu'ils ont été
capables d'aller les chercher de les
faire revenir au canada puis on venu à
mon bureau que ce ponot j'ai commencé à
bright parce que c'était l'option mois
pour moi le plus gratifiant c'est la
correspondance kg avec environ 3,4 me
citoyenne par année certains on se
réécrit le 2 3 fois par année puis quand
je rentre dans la rue mais je n'ai
jamais vu dans l ou patient tousser eux
ils me connaissent ou max otx avis que
des familles mono free ils m'ont dit tu
es maintenant de notre famille tout à
fait